welcome to this video playing Connery
can re from from Norway okay I'm playing
the pawn off against the calc on yeah
this is popular nowadays and here I
found out recently that 94 is an
interesting move i played this a couple
of times this black already here on
video but it's not it does not caught up
yet really that people are aware of this
possibility let's see what it's doing is
taking a while yeah this is something
the most conservative option not bad for
example are played regularly by
grandmaster Draya Queen 85 really wow
okay oh I will destroy its pawn
structure I cannot to help it let's see
how to do this probably Bishop to b5
this is a position with all these pawn
weaknesses where then the Knights will
have a good roll and of course I want to
Castle quickly here yeah that's really a
terrible pawn structure
okay so just just castling check okay so
he's got a light squared Bishop here and
his pawns on c6 and d5 this this means a
couple of things I mean it would be very
nice to get a night to see if I for
example but look at the Kings side this
is an additional problem i'll start with
Queen d2 this looks find it to
protecting the sea porn okay it was not
really hanging but it protects the sea
porn queen possibly going to h6 yeah end
it on this I thought that I'm not in a
pin this is which is very useful I can
actually move the night and I can even
go here that's not a bad idea yeah let's
do 2 h from with the direct that the
direct threat was Queen to f4 now I'm
going rookie one rookie 3 along these
lines
yeah c3 is always hanging okay but I
don't I don't really mind I'm trading on
you one of course okay let's think about
regrouping night jeetu f form intending
both night h5 interesting night h I can
no I cannot go to a five
hmm ok ok she goes rook e8 it's not a
fog a good move Trading everything Queen
takes a two and then I don't have queen
is seven not really night eh five is
good though yeah night h5 is good at the
end of the slide ok so i can do that
check check tween 829 h5 is excellent
for wide yeah okay yeah I'm threatening
to take it and I don't really see a good
reply there's also this yeah the queen
is intending to to end them yeah yeah I
can just take f6 and h7 maybe there is
something better though Queenie three or
something and that's going to be one
Queenie form mmm ok I'll take it it's
probably probably right and now now we
are now Queenie 5pm 25 yeah that's
that's probably correct you centralizing
the Queen Queen V 1 Anakin can now go to
g2g 12 I can go to g2 without suffering
from any a big problem ok so let's
consider I can take here I can also play
Queenie aid Queen the egg King g7 night
h5 check is quite quite attractive night
h5 check King age 6
there is no maid I guess not I did at
least I don't see any any mate okay I
can give the check here back back to f6
oh that's a kind project that's the
right one Jan check check kingi 69 f4 is
easy and here and now i have Queen h8
which I didn't have before because the
h-bond was still existing check check
yeah the night is nice but he made us
better yeah it really took on a tool
very quickly I mean the position was
probably really bad anyway but after
that I think he's just toast I don't
think that black and survive this at
least it looks very very tricky and this
is winning now after Knight f6 there
yeah computers on + + 2 rather quickly
so there should be some sort of oh I
overlooked the medium and what I played
is winning but but I overlooked the mate
here the computer that washes out yet
this is a checkmate checkmate okay check
yeah this is what I did check check I
care what this I really the computer
gives this as only + + 1 this is quite
remarkable I actually didn't calculate
further because i thought this looks so
crazy it's just winning I cannot
leave it
huh remarkable computer does not give a
win here interesting yeah 11 problem is
that if I do this there is probably the
Queen comin with here with jet chicks
check this is a drone oh okay hmm there
is no other way check computer chips
this as a possibility check but how is
this any better I really don't
understand and i can give you a ton of
checks but how am I going to do anything
this is a computer suggestion check
check here change for us oh I'm getting
the bishop with with the serious leak
checks okay as Chang yeah yeah maybe
that this is still a winning chance but
yeah obviously I should play the mate in
three or what the sources it was very
very much easier okay well anyway thanks
for watching